une production du studio
SF bienvenue sans filtre le podcast on
parle ce qu'on ns invités date 7 je
perche Quentin avec moi
Tom cette semaine podcast encore une
fois pour une un deè podcast consécutif
juste les deux là on a parlé la dernière
fois de nos podcast préférés de l'année
qu'on qu'on qu'on a créé qu'on a fait et
là on c'est plus plus sur une note
personnelle notre année 2023 notre année
2024 euh comment qu'on voit ça un genre
de Live Update on a fait en fait les in
et les out de qu'est-ce qu'on veut
évacuer pour 2024 et qu'est-ce qu'on
veut ajouter intégrer à 2024 donc
l'épisode est un peu là-dessus mais
finalement on parle de de plein de
sujets la conversation ça va dans dans
dans plein de directions intéressantes
on vous encourage à faire des in and out
pour 2024 c'est toujours bon bon de
faire une rétrospective sans
nécessairement tomber dans le dans le
kitch de vouloir des résolutions puis
les mêmes résolutions traditionnelles de
se mettre en forme BL BL BL même si on
parle de ça là mais c'est quand même
cool de faire une rétrospective puis de
se poser la question qu'est-ce que j'ai
bien fait qu'est-ce que j'ai moins bien
fait qu'est-ce que je veux mieux faire
qu'est-ce que je veux moins faire non
c'est ça dans l'univers sa jamais
qu'est-ce que ça peut ça pe ça sonne
très ésotérique non mais juste le fait
de de se poser la question de mettre sur
papier ça peut pas faire de tort fait
que Z on vous souhaite du bonheur de
l'amour pour 202
é dans vos études la santé puis euh
RockOn bon podcast le podcast
d'aujourd'hui est présenté par manscape
nos amis de chez manscape qui nous
encourage depuis longtemps et qu'on aime
beaucoup mais on utilise personnellement
leurs produits aujourd'hui on vous parle
du Beard hedger kit là-dedans c'est tout
ce qu'on a besoin pour avoir une barbe
des plus incroyable une pilosité faciale
parfaite il y a six étapes à suivre mais
le le le le dans les mains sur le Beard
Eder dans c'est ça ça c'est la chose la
plus importante c'est le clipper pour la
Bab qui est vraiment
euh qui qui c'est le meilleur Clipper de
barbe que moi j'ai utilisé
personnellement puis ce qui est cool
c'est que il y a comme le le la grille
ici qui qui peut que vous pouvez ajuster
à même le clip vous AZ pas obligé
d'avoir cinq embouts différents pour
faire les côtés pour faire la moustache
si vous voulez une moustache plus longue
vous avez juste besoin de rouler la
petite roulette ça va changer euh la
hauteur et la longueur en fait que vous
voulez de votre barbe c'est moi
personnellement c'est lui que j'utilise
tout le temps évidemment on en parle
souvent mais c'est aussi pour vrai le
meilleur trimer de barbe que j'ai
utilisé de best puis dans le kit ben il
y a tout ce qu'il faut pour nettoyer sa
barbe peigner sa brosser sa barbe après
une paire de ciseaux pour tailler plus
finement tous les petits recoins et
après ça une petite bille à la barbe
qu'elle soit bien reluisante et
incroyable tout ça avec l'odeur
caractéristique des produit manscape qui
est l'odeur que que je porte tout le
temps c'est mon parfum c'est mon body
wash c'est ma c'est mon shampoing de
barbe et avec le nouvel an je suis sûr
qu'il y a du monde dans votre entourage
ou peut-être même vous qui avez comme
résolution de vous laisser pousser la
barbe c'est quand même un commitment
faut faut y aller puis quand faut y
aller ben faut y aller puis assurez-vous
d'y aller avec le meilleur avec les
meilleurs produits donc si vous voulez
le le kit pour le Beard Edger ou
n'importe quel autre produit qu'on parle
tout le temps de chez manscape
assurez-vous d'utiliser le code sans
filtre pour 20 % Rabet et la livraison
gratuite et en plus ça va leur dire que
c'est nous qui vous envoie fait sans
filtre 20 % de Rabet livraison gratuite
c'est le temps de pousser votre barbe
let's
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
go ah j'allais chanter fis
Thum
up jeis en d' prendre mon mon espagnol
même parce que je parle dans 2 jours
c'est vrai pour l'Espagne que là tu
prends des basesespagnol sais moi
j'avais suivi de cours d'espagnol à
l'université mais tu sais quand tu
entretiens pas ça tu c'est juste es
retour à CA d' Mme la se affire que je
peux dire maintenant c'est comme comment
ça se dit ça genre là j'ai j'ai cherché
j'ai chié dans mes culottes dans le taxi
pour être capable de dire ça
au cas que ça arrive on sait jamais ce
pe arriver au cas que ça arrive mais
mais ouais non c'est ça fait que là j'ai
essayé de parce que je me suis dit que
j'étais tellement strict
envers le français
ouais tu sais à Montréal puis on en a
parlé souvent sur le Podcast c'est
tellement quelque chose forcez-vous à
parler français tu arrives là-bas tu
parles zéro Moot je me dis au moins si
quelqu si quelqu'un vient ici puis qui
au moins m'aborde en France a en ESS
baragouiner quelque chose que je
comprends mais que finalement on Swit en
anglais parce que je comprends bien qui
fait son possible ça me dérange beaucoup
moins qu' quelqu'un qui straight up
m'aborde en anglais dans rue tu sais
puis fait là je me suis dit au moins je
vais arriver là puis je va parler au
monde çavoir commander un café mettons
pu personne me pose une question que je
comprends pas je
faire espagnol puis là puis là après ça
tomber en anglais mettons pu
éventuellement pouvoir être capable de
peut-être après 2 mois entretenir une
mini conversation après 2 mois tu sais à
à tous les jours être confronté à ça
puis en apprenant un peu au fur et à
mesure tu devrais quand même t'
j'aimerais ça comme faire Babel aussi
pendant que je suis là-bas tu sais
l'application Babel genre 1 heure de
Babel à chaque 2 jours genre pendant que
je fais du vélo ou quoi que ce soit pour
pour tu sais capable après 2 mois être
comme plus correct parce que je vais
retourner aussi dans l'année là tu sais
fait
que là c'est quoi tu tu apprends comment
là en fait je fais
juste réviser ce que je connaissais m je
regarde c'est
quoi comment je peux justement commander
un café m comment je peux demander les
toilettes sont où comment je peux
dire c'est quoi ça mon fait que là je
fais juste revoir les bases là parce que
là j'ai pas pris le temps de vraiment
retourner dans mes trucs mais il y a
beaucoup de choses que ça revient somme
tout vite tu sais j'étais quand même
capable de faire un exposé oral de 5
minutes sur ma fam et mes amis puis je
me rappelle je me ramène je vis te
conter de quoi je t'ai jamais conté ça
je pense pu là tu m'as parlé de moi en
espagnol oui parce que là faut présenter
nos amis faut présenter les parents de
nos amis puis je me rappelle je voulais
dire que ton
père était gynécologue mais je savais
plus comment dire gynécologue j'ai freé
pu là j'ai fait ce mouvement là pour les
gens qui nous voient pour les gens qui
[Rires]
sont
Golog j'ai tellement me suis tellement
trouvé cave ceux qui nous écoutent je
viens de mettre deux doigts dans les
aires là tu sais est-ce que la classe
rit ou la classe est mal à l'aise ben
tout le monde a comme fait W faire ça le
prof le prof s mis à rire pu là le prof
m'a donné le mot c'est quand quand il
voyait que je Roché pu que je savais pas
si c'était
géologi genre j' j'étais tout mêlé parce
que là tu as appris un texte par cœur
que ve pas comme pas vraiment capable
d'improviser là quand c'est pas ton
langage FA
quand tu apprends un texte par C comme
quand tu apprends les paroles d' comme
quand je rappais je faisais le verse de
l' quand tu chies une place ouais c'est
ça quand tu le connais parc c'est de se
ramener tu sais là j'étais tout mêlé là
il m'a donné comme gynécologue
finalement j'ai fini mon exposé oral
après avoir fait de
tour j'avais oubléavais s jamais compé
trop bon moi j'avais déjà un peu
commencé tu sa la fois qu'on est allé en
République
dominicainecou tu avais travaillé un peu
là-dessus j'avais j'avais comme par
moi-même appris dem justement des bases
là pu honnêtement ça m'avait quand même
servi tu sa rendu là genre j'étais
capable de justement demander des choses
de base puis comprendre un mini peu mais
la la rumeur veut que quand vous avez
vous aviez fumé du pot tu parlais
fluidement espagnol la rumeur veut que
il y a une soirée où est-ce que j'étais
complètement torché défoncé puis que là
je me suis mis à avoir un espagnol de
haut calibre mais le
mais cette légende là vient pas
nécessairement juste de toi il y a du
monde qui dis il parlait espagnol au f
elle vient de genre Sandrine qui était
là qui parlait vraiment un bon espagnol
mais j'avais fait j'avais fait pr
Chequer ça peut-être parce que j'avais
fait une méthode genre ça s'appelit la
pimsler mthode c'est comme un D qui gen
inventé une manière de d'apprendre des
langues vraiment rapidement puis
apparemment c'est comme moi de ce que
j'avais lu c'était comme presque
miraculeux là que comme en un mois genre
tu es vraiment pas pire puis c'est comme
des tu en fait un par jour c'est comme
des des
audios puis ça dure je pense 30 minutes
c'est vraiment mett il va t'apprendre un
mot puis c'est juste à l'oral sais tu
apprends pas c'est vraiment pour la
langue parle puis fa tu apprends un mot
puis fais répéter pu mets dans une
phrase tu répètes la phrase puis après
ça tuends une autre affaire pu là tu
répètes ça reviens en arrière pu tu
répète la première chose que tu as pris
pu la deuxième c'est un peu comme le jeu
tu sais quand tu es en cercle puis làè à
ma valise j' ma valise c'est un peu ça
tu saisit là a un peu de jeu de mémoire
aussi à travers ça c'est comme de la
mémoire puis là mett la première chose
que tu as que tu as appris c'est de plus
en plus long avant qu' tu faire se
répéter mais fini par te le ramener que
là faut que tu t'en souviennes fait que
là c'est comme un exercice de mémoire
puis là le lendemain il te consolide des
choses que tu as pris la veille puis il
fait apprendre des nouvelles affaires
puis pour vrai c'était quand même genre
je pense j'avais fait juste une une
semaine avant de partir j'étais quand
même ouais capable de me débrouiller un
minimum imagine un mois imagine un mois
c'est ça fait que P meod je sais pas
j'avais comme trouvé ça j'avais gen don
des ça les audioobook de ça puis céit
quand même pas
bref c'est ça ouais pour dire queant
dire que je m'en en Espagne pendant 2
mois que sen vient puis je vais
retourner plusieurs fois parce que ceux
qui ben je sais pas si je l'ai dit mais
ma blonde a fait fait continue ses ud en
Espagne pendant un an et demi déjà rendu
là ouais est parti hier est rendu puis
là je vais la rejoindre demain
après-demain fait que non j'ai hâte
j'amène mon vélo tout les kit ça va être
ça va être un trip c'est c'est où en
Espagne en fait Madrid ouais mais tu vas
trip ça il fait 10 gros soleil en ce
moment fait 10 Ah ouais ouais je pensais
qu'il faisait plus chaud à l'année genre
mais pas T b plus chaud à l'année ben
oui non mais je pensais qu'il faisait Mo
10 en haut de 20 à l'annéeain ah non non
non ça c'est Barcelone c'est plus dans
ce coinl parce que M madri c'est quand
même un petit peu plus plus haut
montagnes ok ah Okou en altitude mais
pas en altitude mais un petit peu plus
haut je aller en Espagne mais ça a l'air
incroyable ça l'air fou puis nous on va
voyager en tout cas pe importe on
reviendra de ça quand je reviendrai on
en reparlera mais là on voulait faire un
genre de petit recap un genre
d'épisode plus personnel au niveau de
comme tu sais ça fait longtemps qu'on a
fait ça juste les deux ouais puis tu
sais là c'est un bon moment fin d'année
début d'année tu sais on peut faire un
genre de de je au niveau personnel notre
notre notre notre année 2023 puis
comment qu'on se projet 2024 ça fait que
on s'est dit qu'on ferait un trend in
and out in and outou entre autres
peut-être oua fait que moi je m'pire
petites notesf des petites notes j'ai
des notes mentaleses mental for
commencer ouais ok alternant des in puis
alternant des out ou puis on pourra en
discuter après cha moi mon in c'est un
concept ok là je l'ai workshopé un peu
dans les derniersres de semaines ok
parce que je vais t'expliquer je vais
essayer de faire ça som tout assez
rapidement pour garder l'intérêt des
auditeurs mais c'est le concept du
shibidou ok shibidou chibidou tu inventé
ça ça existe j'ai l' inventé
complètement c'est quelque chose qu'on
sait tous ouais mais que pour des gens
avec un un cerveau cartésien comme le
mien c'est vraiment pratique OK puis le
shibidou est
une une currency fait une une monnaie ok
évidemment inventé mais à laquelle on
doit attribuer euh tout a une valeur en
chibidou dans le fond ok l'argent une
valeur en chibidou mettons 1000 piè
c'est un chibidou j'ai pas encore établi
toutes les les équivalences mais le
chibidou a une valeur dans toutes les
aspects de ta vie puis le but c'est
d'avoir le plus de chibidou c'est de H
devenir
C tu es la personne qui a le plus de
chibidou le Jeff Bezos du shibidou exact
exactement puis le Jeff Bezos du
shibidou c'est pas Jeff Bezos ok parce
que l'argent a une valeur x mais toutes
les autres affaires ont une valeur je
t'explique pourquoi je dis ça on on
parlait de d'investissement de de de
placement de de finances personnelles pu
de toutes ces chosesl c'est tout le
temps mis en compétition avec euh la vie
maintenant
le coup de renonciation à quoi est-ce
que tu dis NON pour placer de l'argent à
quoi est-ce que toutes ces chosesl puis
ces chosesl ont une valeur en chibidou
ouais mettons faire un voyage c'est
beaucoup de chibidou tu payes un petit
peu de
chibidou
monétaire mais tu gagnes beaucoup de
chibidou en tout plein d'autres affaires
sais fait que là ma ce qui que moi et in
pour
2024 c'est d'établir une valeur en
chibidou à toute là tu vas te faire tu
peu fait que là tu vas vraiment faire un
tableau excel avec la valeur tu vas
faire ta contabilité de chibidou je
faire ma comptabilité de chibidou oui à
chaque chose quand tu pèises les pours
et les comptes de faire une affaire ou
une autre ouais ou c'est abstrait en
Chris le bonheur puis ce que ça
t'apporte c'est pas facile évaluer la la
valeur en chibidou de quelque chose
quand même non sauf que tu un voy si tu
prêtes à l'expérience de le faire ben tu
prends le temps de t'asseoir pu tu
prends le temps d'y réfléchir pour de
vrai tu sais ouais ouais mais ton le
voyage c'est combien de chibidou en
croissance personnelle mais tu peux
l'évaluer ça dépend du voyage ça dépend
du voyage voyage à
l'avant voy à
Taiwan toujours revenir en arrière puis
réévaluer t chibidou après tu sais ok
ouais fait que puis après ça le but
c'est de faire une formule puis
d'arriver au plus grand nombre de
chibidou pour 2024 c'est puis tu vois ce
que je te dis là c'est con parce que
c'est un concept qu'on sait gen je veux
la meilleure balance
bonheur sauf que de le mettre plus
concret sans le mettre sur papier dans
un fichier Excel tu sais mais de le
mettre plus concret ça permet de mieux
le comprendre pour moi en tout cas pour
les gens qui ont un cerveau qui
fonctionne comme le mien peut-être que
c'est pas le cas de tout le monde mais
c'est ça moi c'est de mieux évaluer la
valeur de ces affaires là puis capable
de prendre mes décisions en fonction des
chibidou je t'
mets mise en situation sa
parce qu'il y a des cas où est-ce que
quelque chose peut être du chibidou
positif mais que à l'extrême devient du
chibidou négatif ou l'inverse là tu
admettons toi tu es quelqu'un qui qui
s'entraîne beaucoup pu BES productif que
d'être bon qui qui se
met beaucoup de pas de pression mais tu
de d'objectif puis de travail n bon te
dire une journée que je prends pour
vraiment chiller puis écouter des séries
Netflix de temps en temps c'est du
chibidou positif parce que là ça t'aide
à relaxer mais juste dé journé à êre
dans ton lit pu écouter Netflix c'est un
chibidou négatif c'est du chibidou
négatif fait que la même chose peut être
parfois positif parfois négatif oui
parce que il faut que faut que tu vois
aussi le concept d'investissement de
chibidou sais mettons le même même
principe qu'un investissement en bourse
là si aujourd'hui je m'entraîne je suis
productif ça se peut que dans ma journée
globale ça a été une journée à chibidou
neutre ou à chibidou négatif mettons
mais que sur le long terme ça devient un
investissement de chibidou qui va qui
devient positif là tu
sais mett les choix peuvent être aussi
des évaluations à long terme là c'est
pas tout le temps dans l'immédiia tu
sais c'est mettons c'est sûr que si
demain matin je vends toutes mes
affaires puis je fais un voyage de de 6
mois puis que je reviens ici je suis
endetté 30000 pièces euh le chibidou ça
va être négatif même si j'ai voyagé tu
comprends parce que le coût que ça me
coûte sur le long terme est bien plus
grand puis ça rentre dans l'équation
aussi c'est intéressant fait que puis ça
en fait essentiellement ce que ça me
permettre de faire c'est de prendre des
décisions plus éclairées sur qu'est-ce
que je veux faire h tu comprends à place
de de faire de l'anxiété que ce soit
financier parce que je prends des
décisions qui sont pas financières ou de
faire l'anxiété de manquer des choses
parce que je prends des décisions qui
sont financières mais là au moins tu as
ça qui permet de dire ok c'est une
décision qui est la meilleure en terme
de shibidou hm hm très intéressant c'est
mon in pour 2024 cri mais je je ve
peut-être instaurer le chibidou dans ma
vi Essie de voir ça mais tu sais sans
l'instaurer aussi aussi tu sais
drastiquement mais quand même gardeer ça
en têre quand les décisions
arrivent en tout cas ouais mais tu sais
c'est quelque chose que je je fais
incciemment quand quque chose qu'on fait
inconsciemment justement sais quand tu
dépenses quand tu achètes quelque chose
je tu sais c'est tout le temps le le le
le le sac sacrifice ben je veux dire je
sacrifie cet argent là que j'aurais pu
justement placer ou juste
commeus quelque chose l'idée c'est ça
parce que l'argent souvent du moins dans
mes dernières années peut-être parce que
c'est un concern plus grand pour moi
mais la valeur de chibidou que
j'attribuais à l'argent était
probablement trop grande ok ouais ouais
ouais fait que ça faisait que des fois
je faisais genre ok là c'est 100 pièces
puis là genre ou genre je prenais des
deals parce que là j'ai je fais une pub
M de de maillot de bain parce que là
c'est tu sais j'en ai déjà parlé de ça
parce que c'est comme 1500 pièces mais
comme 1500 pièces si c'est juste 1.5
chibidou là puis que genre aller dans un
chalet avec mes amis c'est quatre
chibidou là tu sais tu comprends ouais
ouais qu'est-ce qu' va puis le fait
de le chibidou que tu vas gagner en
argent si on veut
versus que ça te coûte en comment et
bien-être c'est pe être dansatif tu pe
dans le négatif même si ton même si 1500
pièces tu peux quand même être négatif à
cause de ton à cause que c'est a trop de
chibidou négatif lié à ça tu comprends
c'est bien intéressant bien intéressant
la théorie des chibid est encore
workshop là pon paton
pending tu peux tu
pourrais tu pouris commaliser ça puis
devenir fucking juste des gelet marqué
chibidou fucking riche en chibidou là tu
sais là ça devient
tu vends ton jeu mais tu peux juste
l'acheter en
chibid ça ça devient en fait de la
crypto
là tu fais juste créer un scam il faut
que tu me payes un chibidou pu c'est
quoi un chibidou de la monnaie qui
existe pas c'est comme qui vraiment
subjectif il faut que tu me la donnes
ok je vais essayer de je regarde ma
liste on dirait que j'ai rien qui les
chibidou là mais non mais vas-y
n'importe qui puis on va partir
là-dessus là une la premiè que j'ai en
haut c'est une c'est des choses qu'on
veut importer en 2024 impimportter mais
c'est peut-être des choses qu'on fait
déjà qu'on veut continuer oui qu'on peut
mettre l' phase S ou
ouais écoute c'est sûr que les Chid
c'est la BAR ha quand même pour
commencer
lecast
euh j'ai je vais commencer un en lien
avec les podcast OK
je veux
améliorer mes performances au
podcast je trouve que quand que je
regarde des extraits de moi de podcast
je me gosse h je me gosse je trouve que
je cherche mes mots je trouve que je
m'enfge je trouve que je dis genre
mettons tout le temps puis ça me gosse
puis là j'ai fait un effort conscient de
pas dire sa genre mettons à chaque 2
secondes parce que je fais tout le temps
ça puis ça m'énerve puis au début quand
on avait commencé le podcast je me
souviens ouais tu sais genre je me
pratiquais là tu sais je faisais des
cours de diction des fois j'ai fait des
cours de diction mais aussi genre au
début je me souviens je viens de dire
genre ça VI de me déconnecter pour le
reste du podcast c'est ça genre
je tu vois comment que c'est encré c'est
automatique c'est vraiment genre
l'étique en fait ouais puis je me
filmais là tu sais puis je je parlais
d'un sujet puis là je me réécoutais pu
j' j'étais comme ah non c'est pas assez
fluide c'est pas assez intéressant na
puis m'aamené bah tu sais onait à force
de faire le truc après euh je sais pas 6
mois de podcast ben m'né il y a eu des
cours d'diction aussi mais j'ai comme tu
sais je me réécoutais au début j'éis
comme ah ok ça je peux améliorer ça ça
c'était pas bon ça na na na j'ai comme
arrêté de faire ça puis là on dirait que
j'ai j'ai le goût de pas me goser quand
je m'écoute genre puis de fait que ça ça
passe par plein d'affaires je pense ça
passe par juste penser plus à ce dont je
veux parler dans le podcast puis comme
le le le rouler dans ma tête ou même
verbalement une coupe de fois avant me
préparer plus sûrement puis
juste essayer de défaire ces ces fucking
C cl gosant parce que c'est sûr qu'au
début du podcast on s'écoutait beaucoup
juste parce que tu sais c'était nouveau
puis on savait pas c'était quoi qu'on
faisait vraiment puisé on on a comme je
v parler pour moi mais je pense que toi
aussi on a comme arrêté de s'écouter
ouais puis c'est sûr que ça l' changé
ou du moins on a arrêté de porter
attention à ces chosesl h mais je
comprends mais c'est une bonne bon il y
a eu ben tu sais c'est ça je pense que
j'ai vu l'extrait de notre dernier
podcastement que je parle de l'alcool je
gose puis julia a écouté un vieux
podcast je me souviens plus quel en tout
cas elle écouter un vieux podcast comme
tu parlais quasiment mieux je comme not
good tu sais normalement tuas envie
tuessayie de t'améliorer mainant tu
essayes d'aller dans la bonne direction
je comme ça serait fun qu'après 5 ans je
sois meilleur qu'après un an là tu sais
ouais fait que ça j'ai le goû de faire
ça puis
de sur la préparation en général puis
tout puis juste comme plus ouais parce
que je me rappelle même
puis je prépare encore les podcast qu'on
fait avec des invités là tu sais
j'écoute je consomme encore du contenu
tu sais quand qu'on reçoit quelqu'un qui
est allé sur des podcasts j'écoute des
podcasts mais
avant je me surpréparais ouais dans le
sens je pouvais lire deux livres qu'une
personne avait écrit qu'on recevait à
chaque semaine tu sais amé ça devient
pas durable faire ça c c'était too much
puis là je me prépare encore bien mais
c'est vrai que possiblement que euh
c'est ça ça ça il a c'est ça il y a
l'autre la médaille à mé je pense que je
me préparais trop puis là j'arrivais
tellement avec la tête pleine de trucs
que je veux dire ou que j'ai essayé
d'emmagasiner pu que je veux me souvenir
pour pouvoir le dire sur le Podcast que
là ça laissait pas la conversation ça
laissait pas la la spontanéité pu même
que des fois quasiment je figeais parce
que je voulais tellement dire d'affaires
que fin je disais plus rien fait que
trouver genre de balance là-dedans mais
juste je trouve que mon mon mon langage
mon parler et même quand je parle avec
du monde j'ai des
blancs je je genre je trouve ben comme
comme comme en ce moment mais ouais trve
je cherche mes mots en tout CASF j'ai
tout déjà ça ESS de travailler làdessus
je sais pas comment qu'on peut améliorer
ça vraiment moi j'ai l'impression puis
peut-être que ça peut tomber sur les out
là peut-tre qu'on peut faire la
transition avec le un des out que je
voulais
amenerou moi je suis out sur les réseaux
sociaux ouais en 2023 les réseaux
sociaux je laisse ça derrière moi mon
temps d'écran puis mon temps sur TikTok
ou sur Instagram je laisse ça derrière
moi parce que ça me fuck C complètement
ça me fuck le cerveau ça me fr j'ai pu
ma mémoire à long terme je blink souvent
sur des des noms de personnes des mots
que que je sais que je connais que je
sais qu' sont bien emmagasinés dans ma
tête je blink j'ai un problème de rester
attentif à quelque chose je suis pas
capable d'écouter une émission sans
toucher mon sel pour aller refrcher un
feed j'ai ça ce problème c'est fou moi
aussi j'ai la écoutter un film j'ai l'
écoutter un film j'ai à 2h sans checker
mon sel les fois o est-ce que comme là
j'ai là une des affaires que j'ai
commencé à faire en 2024 c'est mettre
mon se en mode ne pas déranger tout le
temps fait que j'ai plus mes
notifications qui popent j'ai plus rien
de ça ça crée d'autres enjeux quand il y
a quelqu'un qui veut t'écrire ma blonde
mettons qu'il faut que je réponde ou
quoi que ce soit mais quand même mais
les moments où est-ce que je me sens le
mieux c'est quand mon se dans une autre
pièce puis on a déjà parlé de ça là sur
le Podcast mais ça c'est un c'est mon
out un de mes out de 2024
c'est les réseaux sociaux puis mon ser
puis je veux plus j'ai l'impression que
je veux juste le le le laisser à partir
de 5h mettons chez nous ou arrêter de le
checker parce que honnêtement je pense
que c'est un vrai problème que j'ai il y
a un couple que je connais
que le le dos d'avait vraiment des
enjeux de de téléphone puis ont des
enfants puis le soir c'est comme c'est
son téléphone c'était beaucoup la la job
là tu sais puis répondre des affaires
puis le Chequer des à sa Blon instorer
la boîte c'est comme quand tu arrives de
travailler là à 5 6h là tu le mets dans
la boîte puis tu le reprends le
lendemain matin c'est comme c'est devenu
ça là tu sais puis ça me paraît comme
comme une comme une l'alternative mais
intéressante quand même là mais ouais
moi je vais continuer l'utiliser pour
poster ouais mais je veux plus consommer
ce ce ce contenu là ça c'est je veux
plus ça ouais fait que ouais c'est mon
h 2024 ouais puis moi j'ai j'ai
j'aimerais ça moi j'ai un in en lien
avec ce qu'on discute en ce moment
recommencer à lire plus oui exact j'ai
l'impression que aussi tu sais pour
exercer le cerveau puis
justement reconnecter refaire des
connexions puis redévelopper mon mon
langage lire je pense ça passe beaucoup
par là puis là le podcast deain je livre
d'un nos invités pu on dirait que comme
lu plus un dans le temps des fites on
dirait que c'est comme une gymnastique
de cerveau qui est qui est importante
puis qui qui se perd rapidement on
dirait quand tu recommmences on dirait
que là justement ça les mots viiennent
plus rapidement puis puis juste tu
deviens une personne juste aussi plus
intéressante puis tu as plus d'affaires
parce que tu sais c'est c'est tuap
prendre des des affaires puis en tout
cas fait que ça en 2024 essayer
de ramener la la lecture dans les la
routine h ça je pense que ça va un faire
quelque chose B un qui peut aider à
décrocher puis genre pas penser tout le
temps soit au travail ou à genre ça
faire là deux comme on disait faire trer
ton cerveau apprendre des affaires puis
euh lâcher ton sel lâcher ton
sel apprendre à ralentir tu sais en tout
cas plein de plein de bienfaits comme ça
ouais qui euh qui sont qui sont
nécessaires pu qui sont comme l'inverse
on dirait de genre le de l'instantanéité
puis genre la S stimulation des rseaux
sociaux puis genre le côté addictif sais
la lecture quasiment ça peut devenir
addictif quand que quand tu lis vraiment
beaucoup puis que tu aimes ça mais tu
sais c'est c'est ça demande un effort là
tu sais puis que ce soit addictif c'est
quand même du stock là pour être un
addicte à la lecture non c'est ça c'est
oua c'est c'est ouais la la puis la la
chose pour la la raison pour laquelle tu
sais moi je disais évidemment à
l'université je lisais cissement
beaucoup là genre
puis depuis que que évidemment j'is allé
à Occupation Double j'ai puis que là je
suis tombé dans comme les réseaux
sociaux puis l'entrepreneuriat par par
la
bande j'ai complètement arrêté j'ai
complètement arrêté genre un peu arrêté
là les dernier livres que j'ai lu c'est
comme on parlait tantôt pour nos invités
au début du podcast ouais quand que on
lisait des livres à chaque fois qu' on
avait invité qui avait écrit un livre
ouais mais j'ai arrêté complètement ceon
j'ai plus rien lu de nouveau ou puis je
le sens tellement je suis plus capable
d'écrire non plus tu sais j'ai plus de
créativité dans l'écriture parce que je
prends pas le temps de m'asseoir puis de
me poser maisê sa que toi si tu écoutes
pas de musique amené probablement que tu
tu as pas de Spar créatif de musique là
tu sais des moments où est-ce que quand
tu faisais du CH tu écoutais juste des
podcast puis j'écoute beaucoup de
podcast mais c'est pas mieux là
d'écouter des podcasts c'est juste du
monde moi j'écoute du monde qui parle
des fois là je parle pas à personne de
ma journée ouais chez nous je travaille
je parle pas à personne j'ai peut-être
deux meetings zoom puis
sinon j'écris des emails je vais
m'entraîner j'écoute des podcasts mais
j'écoute tellement de podcast le monde
qui parle souvent du monde qui parle
d'une game que j'ai déjà regardé je l'ai
vu la game gen je sais le Brown jamesit
quoi c'est juste pour
avoir puis là quand après ça Mons ma je
reviens chez nous puis quandand ma
blonde est à Québec M ouais je suis
comme est là puis je suis comme té
entendre du monde parler fait que genre
je suis comme j'ai besoin de de
chilleroin de relaxer mon cerveau é sur
stimulé toute la journée par tout les
j'ai juste écouter des podcasts la
journée tu sais dans le fond fait que
ouais c'est ça plus mais je suis
d'accord avec toi la lecture c'est un
bon in la lecture puis moi j'ai un autre
in qui est juste
euh avoir des hobbies at large en c'est
quelque chose que 2023 j'ai comme juste
travaillé tu as travaillé beaucoup en
202 10h par jour 7 jours sur 7 là ouais
puis là tout tu as pris le bar là c'est
comme j'étais genre un moin tibétain là
c'était comme je me levais je
m'entraînais je travaillais toute la
journée j'arrivais je me couchais
c'était genre repeat là ouais soit soit
sur venir faire des podcasts ici ou
venir au studio ou genre travailler sur
la musique travailler sur des albums ou
être en tourner des ch ouais c'est ça
fait tu sais c'était comme nonstop puis
on dirait que j'ai fait un blitz aussi
de d'apprendre sur des trucs en lien
avec la musique là genre tu sais plus
DEP dans euh mixer la musique bref puis
là je suis
comme j'ai pas le goût d'être une
personne unidimensionnelle à ce point-là
tu sais genre j'aimerais ça être capable
de parler d'autres sujets un peu être
capable d'entenir des convers re capable
d'avoir tu sais d'être quelqu'un qui a
des tu sais avant mainant j'écoutais
j'écoutais F de films c'est quelque
chose dans le temp des fêtes que j'ai
comme renoué on écoutait quel des films
à chaque soir tu sais genre les
meilleurs films de l'année sais la
stimulation intlectuel qui vient avec ça
puis genre on dirait dans l'université
j'allais au clap une fois par semaine
ouais j'allais au clap le mercredi tout
seul parce que le mercredi j'avais le
droit d'avoir une bière dans salle VIP
j'allais m'asseoir au clap j'écoutais un
film souvent que je savais pas c'était
quoi parce que j'avais écouté toute le
lineup du CLAP quand il y avait un
nouveau film qui rentrait j'y allais à
tous les mercredis je su pas allé au
cinéma depuis 1 an ça doit faire un an
je par aller au cinéma pu tu sais le
cinéma je veux
dire ça so voir Avengers ça se peut que
je t'apprenne pas grandchose sur toi ou
sur le monde ou sur la vie ou quoi que
ce soit mais tu sais sinon je veux dire
le cinéma c'est une fenêtre sur un autre
monde c'est sais c'est c'est c'est c'est
des valeurs c'est des histoires c'est
c'est vrai qu'en 2023 il y a eu beaucoup
de rewatch de The Office à des moments
que j'aurais pu écouter de quoi d'autre
ouais mais c'est parce qu'il faut
laisser de l'espace aussi parce
que tu sais moi quand j'arrivais de mes
ESS de journées là de mes semaine là tu
as pas envie de te forcer le cerveau tu
as pas non plus envie d'écouter un
Bergman ouais tu sais tu as envie
d'écouter de office tu as envie
d'écouter de quoi qui va juste comme tu
peux être à OFF puis genre puis genre
juste comme pour t'endormir là tu sais
fa faut que consciemment il y a du temps
qui soit alloué pour ça ou est-ce que tu
es tu es prêt à recevoir quelque chose
de nouveau qui va peut-être te faire
grandir là tu
sais c'est ça on dirait de de redevenir
une personne un petit peu plus
multiintérêt et multi curieux et on
dirait que j'ai le goût de c'est ça
c'est ça ça commence
par
couper à des places ouais tu as pas le
choix là tu sais mett je t'ai vu aller
dans dernières années là tu sais puis tu
as pas le choix de couper à des place
sinon tu auras jamais cet espace làou
parce que te connaissant chaque fois que
tuas un espace vide tu vas le remplir
mais c'est l'espace vide qu'il faut que
tu laisses respirer pour mettre d'autres
choses éventuellement là tu sais fait
c'est de dire ça c'est mon espace vide
de dire non à des affaires tu sais ça
c'est tough là surtout quelqu'un est
dans un métier que qui contractuel qui a
comme des en musique là tu sais c'est
genre tu t pas de dire non quasiment
parce que dis cette opportunité là
reviendra pas mais il vont en avoir une
autre sa faut juste pu là tu es rendu à
un spot au moins que tu as un peu cette
sécurité là de comme il va en avoir une
autre ouais c'est ça le stress de comme
E je v d je pas travailler dans 6 mois
dans un an de moins en moins là surtout
avec le studio qui atteint une certaine
stabilité c'est comme je veux tout avoir
de quoi tu sais fait que là je je sais à
chaque année d'près moi si on Fa si on
faisait le si on faisait des flashback
de toutes les les les genres de de
moment euh comme ça que qu'on a fait des
live updatees avec le studio je pense
que j'ai dit ça à chaque fois mais tu
sais c'est ça j'arrive quand même à le
faire pu je pense
que 2023 j'ai travaillé en Chris
mais je suis pas tombé dans le Dark Side
sais ouais tu sais c'est comme j'ai
réussi quand même à dormir 8h par nuit
puis à faire du sport tu sais je suis
pas tombé en mode
genre burnoutouais fa on on essaie de g
ça comme ça puis ben en fait même encore
respirer un petit peu plus pour avoir le
temps de comme vivre un peu plus mais
sinon sinon gardz genre jeis quand même
fier de sil y a un in à continuer c'est
espèce de de rigueur slash routine là
que j'ai maintenant que j'avais pas
avant dans ma vingtaine de comme je
travaillis un peu n'importe quand je fa
travailler jusqu'à 3h du matin à mené
puis là une journée pas en puis une
journée tandis que là c'est comme j'ai
ma petite routine sa j'ai mon le matin
après ça je va travailler après ça je
reviens pu sais c'est comme c'est plus
régulier puis ce qui fait que je peux en
faire vraiment plus vraiment plus
efficace en fait qu'avant je comprends
moi m c'était la première fois cette
année décembre ouais puis je savais que
mon voyage en Espagne s'en venait fait
que j'ai pas comme surcrigé mon affaire
mais décembre quand fallait finir le Q4
puis que tout le monde avait de l'argent
à à dépenser en publicité
ud c'est la prière fois de ma vie que
que je me
disais je pourrais pas maintenir ça
longtemps je pourrais pas maintenir ça
encore de mois mett tu sais cette espèce
de charge mentale et de travail que
j'avais pendant le mois de
décembreand quand on a
fermé toute le 23 puis que là tout le
monde est parti qu' y a pas de message
qui rent je me sentais comme Bilbo quand
qui dit genre j'ai besoin de longues
vacances là tu sais genre faut je m'en
je pr un bateau vers les terres immortel
dem matin jeis tellement brûlé puis là
avec tu sais les vacances c'est jamais
vraiment reposant parce que tu as tout
le temps des parties de famille qui
finissent plus puis euh ouais mais là je
savais que mon mon voyage en Espagne
s'en va même si c'est pas un voyage que
je que je mets à tout à OFF parce que je
vois quand même on continue à travailler
mais je savais que j'allais pouvoir un
peu décrocher la bas je savais que ça
s'envenait fait que j'ai pas trop
corrigé mais je pouvais pas genre je
savais que ça allait pas cont continume
j'étais en train de me dire bon c'est
quoi les les options pour que ce soit
pas ça parce que ça pas de sens là tu
sais ce qui' ce qui m'amène aussi à mon
out ouais on en a parlé lors du du recap
des best of
mais le 31 décembre on est allé sur
grand allé avec avec des amis ma blonde
pour
le le tobogan a que puis on s'est quand
même saoulé la gueule ok puis le 1er
janvier je me suis réveillé quand même
l' veille ouais comme mal de cœur mal de
tête pas fresh pour la nouvelle année là
j'ai ouvert mon
cel comme j'is allé dans le salon j'ai
ouvert mon se je bu mon café pu là j'ai
vu rich roll qui est du rich roll
podcast qui lui a eu des gros problèmes
de consommation plutôt dans sa vie mais
que là il est sub depuis comme je pense
genre 25 ans puis il se filme puis il
dit bon matin à tout le monde puis dit
je suis sûr qu'il y en a ce matin qui me
voit qui écoute ça qui ont mal au cœur
mal à tête qui sentent pas frais qui
sentent pas prêt à partir la nouvelle
année puis il est sur son vélo il est
sur son trainer en train de s'entraîner
dehors genre gros soleil de la
Californie puis dis-moi être sobre is
the gift that keep on giving parce qu'
toutes les fois que je me réveille dans
cette ét là quand je sais que un 1er
janvier par exemple il y a beaucoup de
monde qui sont hover lendemain veille
qui se sentent mal qui ont mal à tête il
d à chaque fois que je me sens même je
suis grateful de ma décision d'avoir
arêté de consommer puis je me suis dit
out pour 2024 l'alcool ah ouais terminé
pour 2024 ouais ouais c'est fini parce
que je me dis ah une bière ici là mais
si je fais une bière ici et là je je
juste c'est pas avoir de tu sais quand
Onon va arriver dans une soirée je v
dire j'en prends j'en ai pris au bord
l'autre fois j'en ai pris sur une
terrasse je vis en prendre à soir alcool
2024 c'est terminé out ouais puis tu
sais dans des soirées tu de temps en
temps puis là la soirée tout le monde
vire puis là tu comme ah ouais puis là
tu comme tu veux pas être
celui tu dis ah t qu'à faire j'en ai
pris deux j'en prends trois j'en prends
quatre on dirait que c'est plus facile
de tomber dans le dans la loupe dans
l'engrenage exact moi m ça va faire
quasiment un an bientôt ça doit faire 11
10 11 mois là que j'ai pas bu puis ça me
manque pas pas non c'est ça aucun regret
aucun
les les quelques moments où est-ce que
je me suis dit à soir ça arrêté le fun
c'est arrivé quelquefois c'est vraiment
rien à comparer en chibidou là mettant
là c'est vraiment rien à comparer de
comme tout ce que j'ai gagné en
justement là me sentir bien me sentir
fres me
sentir j'aurais pas sais on parlait que
j'avais une grosse année ça aurait
jamais été possible avec une brosse par
semaine dans lifesty que tu avais avant
quand tu faisais cover band puis que
genre tu finissais ça hash à 3h là sous
quand même là parce que tu avais pris
des chots puis de la bière la soirée tu
aurais pas pu faire ce que tu fais là
avec ça j' ce que je faisais là puis
j'aurais à l'époque puire vraiment mieux
dans F ce que je faisais là justement
quand que je jouais là avec TR qu chot
puis TR qu peintes dans le corps là
j'étais pas au top de ma game j'étais
pas mon best non puis si tu avais pas vé
ton char après tu serais retourné chez
vous qu
chose tu aurais pas eu envie d'aller
manger la grosse Poutine à
3h30 aussi tout ça non je te dis aucun
regret le seul affaire que ça demande
c'est une tolérance
à avoir une bonne tolérance à à la pas
la confrontation mais ouais la pression
des autres la pression la pression
sociale en fait la pression des autres
d'être capable de dire veux-tu sais
mettons au jour dein just dans ma
famille un petit de mousse non
merci d'être capable de faire non merci
puis que même person comment
ça je bois pas puis genre pas parce que
je P beaucoup de gens qui vont dire ou
juste oui parce que c'est comme c'est ça
qui ouais qui on pas nécessairement la
ver de Mousseau c'est le bon exemple là
tout le monde on fait un chin chin au
verre de Mousseau c'est
comme puis en bout de ligne le verre de
mousseux change pas grand chose on s'en
fout c'est pas une question du verre de
mousseux puis c'est juste moi comment
mon cerveau fonctionne c'est plus facile
c'est la porte existe pas ça ça a été ça
avec le avec la viande ouais ça a été du
jour lendemain c'est ça n'est plus une
option tu sais fait que c'est pas un
genre de ah ben de temps en temps le
temps en temps je sais qu'il va il va
creeper in tu sais il va revenir puis il
va puis il va me tenter tout le temps va
tout le temps être là va tout le temps
me déranger versus quand c'est pas une
option ça ça te dérange même plus dé
parler de ça mais mais bref ouais
l'alcool c'est ça faut juste je pense
que bien du monde dans le fond que
peut-être que il aurait pas bu là tu
sais il aurait pas eu envie de boire
sauf que juste le le petit moment de ah
je ten prend la petite tension de ben
ouais pourquoi pas juste pour pas dire
non pour pas déplaire pour pas faut être
capable de déplaire un peu ça c'est ça
je l'ai réalisé parce que j'ai décidé de
faire ça là pour la nouvelle année tu
sais le premier en me levant la décision
été prise ouais quand j'ai vu ce clipl
là de roll il y avait plus de doute que
c'est ça que je faisais genre c'était
pas c'était pas ah peut-être jeis penser
c'était comme non c'est ça je me sens
comme une merde je pourrais être en
train de m'entraîner je pourrais être en
train d'aller dehors faisait beau soleil
le premier en plus puis je suis resté en
cavané chez nous parce que j'étais
j'avais mal à à tête je je pourrais être
dehors prendre l'air prendre un café
marcher dehors dans le Vieux Québec
aller courir aller faire du vélo sur mon
TR je pourrais faire plein d'affaires
que je fais pas maintenant à cause de ça
puis la décision était prise puis
enttemps on est allé manger dans la
famille de ma blonde dans le dernier
jour puis j'ai fallu que je dise non
ouais puis c'était cétait comm ah tu es
s tu es s tu es S puis à chaque fois ça
j'ai rempli vos ver tu es sûr d'en veux
pas non merci tu es sûr comment ça ben
j'en veux pas tu sais puis c'est genre
une soirée c'est pour ça c'est ça qui
est tof là tu sais puis andra moi même
si tu sais je va commencer par dire NON
MERCI puis si la personne insiste je v
juste dire ah je bois pas gen ou je bois
plus ouais puis là tu as tout le temps
de l'air de la personne qui avait qui
avait un problème là c'est que il y a
une raison là tu sais même mon
père mon mon père il a su ça parce que
tu sais dans le fond j'en parle jamais
là à part à part là puis 2 semaines
ouais par de dernier Podcast ouais c'est
ça j'en parle jamais là tu sais puis
c'est juste comme dans des
occasions que justement il y a de
l'alcool j'en prends pas que les gens
s'en rendent compte sinon je veux dire
bon j'ai j'ai pas sa dans ma bio
Instagram là tu sais oua bon mais pu je
pense ça mon père s'en rendu compte a
pas longtemps là tu sais puis plus temp
des fit tu allé voir ma ma blonde pu tu
es comme dou ouais il bois plus il tu
arrivé quelque chose tu sais c'est comme
c'est comme c'est inquiétant là comme
c'est bizarre quelqu'un qui boit plus
mais en même temps quand tu dis je bois
plus ben le monde te sac la pai aussi
parce que là c'est mieux dire c'est
mieux de dire je bois plus que je bois
pas parce que je bois pas ça fait qu un
peu non moi je bois pas tu sais comme si
c'est au-dessus des autres qui boivent
là de dire je bois plus c'est comme non
non j'ai déjà bu puis genre je bois plus
ça sonne plus comme j'avais un problème
puis moi c'est pas au moins le monde
pose pas de question ce que je bois pas
c'est comme lui il est végan puis il
boit pas je PL dans gr à Noël là c'est
ça moi aussi je me dis le monde doiv
tellement trouver que je genre monsieur
restriction là pu tu sais moi je me sens
tellement pas comme ça mais non c'est ça
l'affaire moi je me sens tellement pas
comme le gars qui veut tout contrôler
dans sa vieê au même soup metton que je
te parle la famille de ma blonde CIT de
la fondue puis là moi j'avais tu sais
c'est comme donnez-moi de la patate une
patate des brocolis du tofu genre d' je
vais être le GS le plus heureux de la
planète tu sais je peux même l'acheter
je vais l'amener je me senens c'est bien
correct faire ça sauf que en même temps
il y avait mon plot fondu avec du
bouillon végé j'is là me semble que je
suis lourd là pour tout le monde tout le
monde est là tout le monde mange leur
fondu je suis le seul qui j'aimerais
j'aimerais mieux qu'il ait pas de viande
dans tu sais dans ma fondu à moi ouais
comme c'est pas grave au pire je mange
juste mes affaires pas dans fondu c'est
ça c'est juste un souper tu sa c'est pas
la fin du monde mais optimal si tu sais
vous me demandez qu'est-ce que je veux
je suis comme il me semble que le monde
doit me trouver chiant mais en même
temps quand je suis dans ma vie tous les
jours ça j'y pense même pas ouais
surtout viande l'alcool c'est même pas
c'est pas commencé encore mais j pense
pas j'en achète pas pense pas puisas
c'est qu' on a de l'air d'en parler tu
sais moi justemental par que monde parle
parce que le monde t'en parle puis
mettons moi l'alcool justement d'aller
dans les parties de famille là c'est
arrivé plus souvent que j'en ai parlé
parce que la situation de vu un verre
non comment ça puis là je vois pas ah
oui comment ça puis là ça engage une
discussion mais j'ai pas nement envie
d'avoir cette discussion là puis dans ma
vie tous les jours genre je v jamais
faire un post sur Instagram genre contre
l'alcool ou genre buvez pas c'est pas je
pas engagé pour ça là ouais c'est c'est
c'est fait que mais finalement tu te
ramass à avoir cette discussion là
vraiment plus souvent que tu voudrais
l'avoir ou que tu devrais l'avoir juste
par que parce que c'est pas la norme
fait ouais exact c'est ça mais c'est pas
parce que quelque chose est pas la
norme que que que c'est pas la bonne
chose à faire là tu sais ouais
ouais c'est ça puis même chose pour le
véganisme là dans le fond tu sais les
conversations justement là moi le
l'oncle de ma blonde il me posait plein
de questions puis il était intéressé
pour de vrai à mon raisonnement sauf que
là le monde écoutait mes réponses fait
que là j'étais quand même assez à table
là tout le monde m'écoutait moi parler
de comme de mon raisonnement face à
l'écologie puis à l'éthique animale
j'avais l'air de preacher comme j'ai
déjà fait avant mais je veux juste
répondre à ce que le monde me dise mais
en même temps j'aimerais beaucoup mieux
qu'on parle du Canadien de Montréal en
ce moment pour vrai tu sais j'aimerais
vraiment mieux pas être le centre
d'attention de parce que je fais de
différent des autres sauf que ça vient
avec sauf que une fois évidemment
c'était la première fois que je
rencontrais tout ce monde là puis
éventuellement j'imagine que ça va ça
sera plus le sujet de conversation là
c'est ça TR tu te sens comme
si moi j'ai pas envie de faire la morale
aux gens dans vie tu te sens comme si tu
fais ça mais tu veux pas que ça soit ça
tu sais justement mettons mon beau
frère à à Noël tu sa qui aime le vin
puis qui boit du vin puis que tu lui
pour lui c'est un intérêt dans sa vie
puis tout puis là on parle de ça puis ah
ouais tu bois plus puis il me pose des
questions pourquoi jeis B tu sais
comment je me sens mais aussi sur la
santé plus en plus de comme de de de de
preuve scientifique là tu sais que de
l'effet néface de l'alcool ah ouais mais
tu sais pu après ça des fois les gens
tombent en mode justification ah mais tu
sais moi sais je bois vraiment juste je
bois pas tout seul je juste plus
socialana c'est comme mais même si tuis
seul fais ce que tu veux ça dérange pas
pas besoin de te justifier ou te
défendre de quoi que ce soit ouais oua
ouais c'est clair mais moi je Tavais mis
dans ma liste aussi le ben tu sais dans
le fond c'est pas ben c'est un in à
continuer mais pas d'alcool ou un out
bref mais c'est ça moi c'est ça fait
partie des choses qui qui i guess là
pour rester puis queas même pas au
départ planifier même tuas même pas
voulu comme une coupure franche là c'est
juste comme
ça me tente pas de boire aujourd'hui à
tous les jours ouais mais là plus ça va
plus plus comme ce n'est une coupure
franche puis que je suis bien àaise avec
ça
ouais yeah c'est bon ça ce qui m'amène à
la caféine ouais ça aussi m je me
questionne là-dessus pourquoi on dirait
que
ça j'ai pas envie d'être
d'avoir d'êre esclave de quoi que ce
soit puis le C c'est rentré
tranquillement puis sais mett 2 3 ans je
Buais même pas vraiment de café h mais
là je trouve que je suis rendu le gars
qui a besoin de son
café je suis pas sûr que ça me t j'ai ma
réflexion est pas terminée là-dessus
parce que des fois j'ai l'impression
quand même que tu niveau productivité
concentration ça pe être mais tu faisess
la stratégie de pas le boire enement oua
je bois pas parce que moi ce que je fais
maintenant puis là je me suis acheté une
lampe une
lampe je sais pas c'esti euh solaire
genre une lampe qui qui simule le soleil
le matin quand qu' fait pas beau dehors
sinon quand il fait beau dehors je va
marcher 15 minutes dehors toutes les
matins h puis où je vais courir mainant
quand qu' fait quand j'ai c'est ça
planifié dans dans mon entraînement ou
sinon je me mets la larme dans face le
matin pu là ça me ça me crinque mon gars
pour la journée là puis après ça je
prends juste comme un café ou deux cafés
dans la journée après 2h puis je vois
pas le négatif h toi ton ce que tu
trouves qui est négatif c'est que tu
sens que tu en as besoin tout le temps
parce que moi mettons des fois là je la
prends juste parce que je veux le
prendre parce que quand je reviens soit
de ma course le matin ou quand je
reviens de m'exposer au soleil j'ai j'en
ai pas besoin pour être efficace puis
actif h c'est juste que je le prends
parce que j'aime ça je trouve c'est bon
puis il y a des bénéfices pour
l'entraînement
ouais puis pour la santé
cardiovasculaire aussi
toi c'est juste que tu sens que tu étais
addicte adct s tuasant besoin pour
fonctionner comme du monde B là c'est
rendu ça fait partie de ma mon quotidien
là de
prendre de prendre au même que tu
entraîné
ouais mais tu sais parce qu' des trucs
qui font partie de notre quotidien qui
sont pas no non je sais je sais mais tu
sais
avant j'ai l'impression que avant que je
prenne du café je fonctionnais bien
aussi puis tu sais pas l'imession ça
m'amène tant de plusvue Versus de de
comme je sais pas là avoir besoin
d'arrêter au team me PNER mon CAF ou
d'avoir d'avoir c'est comme genre de
puis je sais pas juste aussi la dépense
quotidienne de
comme du café tu à maison c'est pas P là
mais genre aller au café dans CAF dans
le myland ton Laté à H pièces là dans le
je vois souvent dans le ah je su
tellement tout le temps mais c'est sûr
un matin je arrêté un café avec ma sœur
on est allé dans le maen justement au
café alphabet je pense puis j'ai pris un
Laté d'AV ça cte s pièces c'est sûr que
ça c'est pas bon mais il est bon bon le
café mais ouais pas une bonne habit
sinon chez nous j'ai le café instant du
du Costco puis un café instant moi m
quand je t' allais amen je allais en
entraînement Martinique puis là-bas tout
ce qu'on avait céit du café instant puis
le goût du café instant me ramène
instantanément là ce qu'on faisait le
matin on se réveillait on était on avait
une maison qui était sur la plage
littéralement fait qu'on av on allait on
faisait notre café instant on se faisait
bouillir de l'eau on mettait un café
instant dans une tasse on allait
s'asseoir sur un banc en avant de la mre
avant nos entraînements genre à 7h puis
là on buvé notre café instant puis quand
je bois du café instant maintenant ça me
ramène là tout le temps puis j'espère ça
va me ramener là pour toujours parce que
c'est le meilleur souvenir que j'ai de
le café puis à chaque fois que je prends
du café instant ça me ramène là puis le
goût ça me dérange même pas j'aime ça
maintenant tellement tellement la le
souvenir est fort ouis ouais mais moi tu
sais euh moi j'aime les café filtrre là
j'ai pas besoin d'avoir un le genre le
l'espresso euh ouais quand tu le goûtes
c'est comme du vin quand tu goûtes le
café next level à côté d'un café de
merde h là tu sais enent guemet mettons
tu le goûtes mais quand tu prends juste
le café bot gamme puis tu le compares
pas à genre le café fait en Italie par
le master CAF sais le maître du de
l'espresso ben tu le vois pas la
différence moi je serais capable de te
dire un 20 à 300 pièces ver V à 12
pièces je serais capable de te le dire
si j'é gooute un après l'autre tu sais
mais je serais pas nécessairement
capable de te le dire si j'é gooute un
tout seul peut-être là mais encore là ça
ser
surprenant je fait l'exercice l'autre
fois là j'avais acheté un vin P est
comme tombé en en amour avec du vin en
boîte ok c'est genre elle achète ça à
l'épisserie puis ça fait la job puis
l'autre jour j'avais amené une bonne
bouteille de vin blanc pisé avait son
vin ouais puis là j'ai fait la le goût
mon la différence puis ça tu t'en rends
compte tu t'en rends compte t RTE ouis
que ça me demande aussi c'est comm
est-ce que aussi on
attribue tu
sais de la valeur à quelque chose
justement que le Craft est
plus c'est plus complexe puis que tu sa
ça vaut plus cher dans parce que on
projette aussi que c'est nécessairement
meilleur
quand Ben m ça là c'est une question qui
est plus grosse que juste cette question
là parce que on peut l'attribuer à plein
de choses la valeur des chose est
souvent attribué par des spécialistes
l'exemple d'une toile ouais une toile là
un expert de l'art visuel va voir une
toile faire ah ça c'est magnifique moi
je vais le voir je va faire aurais pu
chier ça sur une à terre là tu sais sur
une toile à terre j'aurais gché de la
peinture dessus pu ça aurait fait ce que
je vois là fait pour moi ça a aucune
valeur mais pour le spécialiste ça l'
toute la valeur un vin qui vaut 10000
pièces la bouteille oua pour un
spécialiste ça va être ça c'est la
meilleure chose qui est arrivée au monde
moi tu vas me le donner je pourrais me
torcher avec tu sais ouais ouais parce
que c'est du vin ouais oui parce que je
connais pas çais oua oui mais tu sais le
vin ouais ouais mais le café mais tu
sais le v mettons elleul là h tu sais on
dirait que psychologiquement la
bouteille à 50 pièces est meilleur que
la bouteille à 25 pièces c'est deux fois
plus cher mais je veux dire je je suis
pas expert là mais j'imagine qu' peut
avoir cement des facteurs qui fait en
sorte que la bouteille est plus chère là
genre d'où vient comment c'est tu sais
com comment compliqué c'est de
l'exporter c'est quoi genre la capacité
de production de cette place là
peut-être que l'autre place qui en font
cissement beaucoup puis qui sont plus
efficaces même c'est moins cher
peut-être bien meilleur là tu sais en
sens que
c'est pas parce que ta bouteille est 18
pièces qui est à chier puis l'autre en
tout cas mais bref là c'est un domaine
que je connais pas non non mais là mais
mais mais moi je pense vraiment que
c'est que que les si tu es si tu es
c'est néophite le terme pour dire tu es
nouveau dans quelque chose nble si tu es
un
noob newbi là si tu es un newbi reste
sais si tu un newbi dans quelque chose
qui te procure du plaisir reste un newbi
dedans H c un newbi dans le café là
reste un newbi parce que ça va coûter
bien trop cher sinon
ouou tu sais commen à s'acheter une
machine d'espresso qui coûte 5000 pièces
la machine plus le grinder à 2500 pièces
plus la petite affaire pour brasser plus
les timers plus les pesés plus tout plus
le café comme tel tu sais si tu es un
newbi comme moi tu achète le café
instant au Costco ça te procure du
bonheur ça me procure probablement
autant de chibidou maintenant que le
gars oua qui a son sa machine qui coûte
10000 pièces quand que je prends ma tuse
de café le matin là ouais moi ça me
ramène à Martinec lui il tripe son café
c'est autant de chibidou ouais ou ouais
sauf que son coup de chibidou lui de
dépense manire il pasme plus grand que
la mien ouais mais bref pour la caféine
je sais pas je sais pas c'est quoi la
conclusion que je veux mais je pense que
j'aimerais ça que ça ça devienne juste
plus quelque chose que comme c'est un
plaisir mais que c'est pas la nécessité
ou c'est pas nécessairement le truc au
quotidien que mett on va prendre un café
ou et on s'arrête dessus cette fois-ci
prendre un café mettons on fait du CH
puis on se prend un café é gllacé à deux
tu sais mett whatever dir j'ai tout mant
je regarde mon père qui s prend pas ses
deux cafés il a mal la tête j'ai pas le
goût de ouis de me rendre d'avoir besoin
j'ai pas pris mon café je CR c'est deux
TR jours de pour le retirer mettons ce
mal de tête là moi je l'ai déjà fait
quand je nangeais là pour avoir plus
d'effet finalement c'est pas prouvé que
que ça change quoi que ce soit là mais
je le faisais où est-ce que j'arrêtais
de prendre du café avant les
compétitions pendant 2 3 jours tuas mal
la tête c'est étant
mais la différenceent le café l'alcool
c'est que le café des bienfaits reconnus
pour la santé
ou la
différence mais c'est bon c'est un
bonch c'est une réflexion ouis
ouais sinon j'ai écrit qu j'ai écrit
on a parlé de tout
ça je pense la seule chose qui dans ma
liste qu'on a pas parlé c'est plus de
sexe plus de sexe plus de sexe plus de
sexe on parle-moi de ça plus de sex
parle-moi de ça
euh toi ça fait combien de temps que tu
avec ta blonde là euh ça va faire 2 ans
ça va faire 2 ans en mars ouais j'ai
l'impression que 2 ans là ouais c'est le
2 ans c'est la fin de la lune de miel
euh peut-être dans une relation normale
mais nous éé qu'on é à longue à longue
distance souvent j'ai pas l'impression
que ça fait 2 ans ok j'ai l'impression
que ça B tu sais je veux pas faire de
comparaison à combien de temps ça peut
prendre là mais j'ai pas l'impression
que ça fait 2 ans ça fait moins 2 ans
j'ai l'impression que ça fait moins que
2 ans tu sais j'ai eu des relations de 2
ans dans le passé puis c'est crissement
plus routinier là ou là dans 2 jours je
pars en Espagne c'est
comme quand même pas en routinier pas
tant routinier là ouais mais en tout cas
nous autres à 2 ans là ça fait combien
de temps que vous êtes enens 3 ans 3 ans
puis on dirait que ma blonde a qui track
de toutes nos relations sexuelles parce
que elle rentre tout ça dans son
application une application gen sur son
s'appelle flow là c'est comme sur son s
menstruel aussi puis sur sa fertilité
puis bref rentre ça
là-dedans fami pourquoi sa
sait combien de fois qu'on le fait
comprends puis sa les deux premières
années c'était comme ça all au quand
même au là c année ça quand même ça t ça
t quand même moins ça t pas fort pas pas
fort là ça ça quand même probblement
bien plus que bien du monde probablement
ou mais moinsê
de on est quand même de à la base mais
là c
comme ça pas à faire peur que ça c'est
des podcasts là mais moi il m'a dit au
début avec ma blonde là c'était deux
fois par jour à tous les jours pendant
les deux premières années j'ai fait M
vous êtes des malades vous êtes des
malades ça c'est deux choses c'est tu es
un malade et deux comment t dans une
journée pour ça c'est comme tu
travailles dessus genre c'est comme jeis
pas travailler fort je sais pas non mais
c'est ça c'est ça ça dépend de ton ton
style de vie aussi là mais moi je pense
que y a il y a il y a ça aussi je pense
que naturellement au début tu découvres
puis là c'est comme tu sais c'est c'est
tuas plus c'est pas je plus nouveau puis
c'est plus le Spark là tu sais puis àé
ça ça ça s'estompe un peu puis que c'est
c'est correct dans un sens parce que
c'est tu es pas obligé de de d'avoir les
relations sexuelles tout le temps t les
jours il y a pas de nombre qui sont qui
qui représentent le succès le bon nombre
c'est celui qui fait l'affaire au deux
tu sais
mais mais j'ai l'impression que c'est ça
cette année mais tu sais c'est je pense
c'est souvent des trucs reliés à
d'autres genre au stress ouais justement
à la charge de de travail là tu sais
puis qui fait que genre après une
journée à CRISM
genre stressé puis comme avoir la tête
pleine
d'affaires pas nement la tête à ça m là
tu et ver puis puis aussi on a plus
l'âge qu'on avait on est moins c'est
fatiguant non mais non non mais dans le
sens on est moins on a moins d'énergie
vitale qu'on a déjà eu là puis juste moi
j'ai j'ai établi des dangers puis des
pièges auxquels fallait que moi je fasse
attention pour justement garder ça mais
la première chose c'est briser les
schémas ou parce que ça arrive vite que
tu tombes dans les même pattern dans la
même puis là tu as l'impression de
répéter la même relation sexuelle parce
que tu sais qu'est-ce que toi tuaimes tu
sais qu'est-ce que l'autre taime fait
que rapidement vous retomber dans même
dans le même
pattern le même script ou sexuel puis là
en le script devient moins intéressant
parce que tu fais CR c'est le même
script à chaque fois genre c'est moins
c'est rendu ouais c'est ça c'est rendu
comme un scénario qu'on connaît qu'on
fait parce SCP utilitaire dans le sens
que comme tu as eu ton orgasme mon
orgasme ok c'est bon on passe à autre
chose ouis ça c'est ça c'est un danger à
guetter un autre danger à guetter pour
moi personnellement c'est l'heure ouais
dépasser 10 c'est fini a aucune chance
aucune chance puis non seulement
dépasser 10 mais le Best c'est avant de
souper là le Best c'est avant de souper
tu es encore fres puis non seulement ça
mais ça peut même faire l'effet que
d'aller
courir un 10 kg peut faire sa qu quand
on parle de l'énergie mobilisée là quand
on parle du stress avec N par de ça dire
quandas juste un brain fog tu vois plus
clair tu as l'IM de pas être capable de
réfléchir va danser dans le salon va
courir 5 kg puis là ça se claire mais ça
ça peut faire la même chose fait quand
tu reviens du travail mais 5h
6h tu es pas encore trop fatigué tu es
juste comme un peu brain fog de CR de
prendre ce moment là puis de dire ça ça
être le moment où est-ce que on va avoir
une relation sexuelle m ben là ça vient
faire ça ça fait que tu es pas fatigué
tu connectes aussi en revenant tu sais
des fois tu es comme un peu dans ta tête
un peu en tabarnac après la journée
parce a ple d'affair à tu pensais tutais
un peu tu couris après des email
quelqu'un qui t'a fait chier tu sais
toutes ces chosesl mais là tu arrives
chez vous tu encore un peu en tabarnac
fait que tu connectes pas vraiment tu
parles pas vraiment à ta partenaire mais
là de faire ok non ce moment là nous
permet en plus de reconnecter de clairer
brain fog de laisser la m du travail au
travail après ça tu vas prendre une
douche tu fais le soup tu chill dans le
lit puis là non là j'allais dire c'est
fait
pas que c'est une corvée à cocher mais
tu as pas l'espèce de genre et là me
semble ça fait une semaine qu'on a pas
couché ensemble tu te sens un peu obligé
de devoir faire de quoi après le souper
quand tu es brûlé pu ça tente moins ça
c'est pas bon ça là tu sais fait le
timing c'est l'affaire principal ben une
des de une des trois affaires la
troisième affaire c'est juste la fatigue
quand je fais 2h de de
d'entraînement ça ça arrivera juste pas
ça peut pas arriver c'est tu c'est la
fatigue physique c'est vraiment quelque
chose puis je lisais non seulement ça
mais je lisais sur la libido des
athlètes d'endurance des athlètes élites
puis c'est vraiment il y a vraiment une
corrélation là dans les ces
d'entraînement c'est pas les plus
[__] c'est pas les plus baisard c'est
pas les plus baisard ah ouais ouais non
mais je peux comprendre ben quand tu es
brûlé tu es brûlé là BR mais c'est çait
moi c'est tu vois ça
comme comme une activité physique
ouais mais c'est pas une question de le
voir comme ça amen c'est just je band
pas je band pas je comprends mais tu sa
mett si tu dis que que je fasse une demi
heure de moins de course mettons ouais
ou ouais oui parce que tantôt ça va y
aller au T oui mais mettons ouais c'est
ça oui mais aussi d'essayer de pas te
coordonner parce que la mar dire M mais
de il y a des journées où est que tu
fais juste un J de 45 minutes mettons
puis le J de 45 minutes tu es pas mal
plus fresh que ta long run du dimanche
où que tu viens de faire 30 kg es tu es
[__] là tu sais tuas envie de dormir en
boule ouais ouis ouais moi c'est les
trois enfaires j'ai ciblé ouais ouais
ouais mais c'est ça planifier du temps
pour ça c'est comme n'importe quoi là
c'est comme si tu veux toutes les in
qu'on parle ou toutes les sa les trucs
que tu FAAS acheter dans ta dans ta
routine ou tu sais là on parle de c'est
le début de l'année c'est les
résolutions puis tout c'est comme tout
tout vient à si tu veux incorporer
quelque chose de nouveau dans ta vie ou
tu me place dans ton horreur sais c'est
ça exact puis tu sais la
sexualité d'un côté tu tu veux qu'il
reste une certaine spontanéité mais je
veux dire ça si tu rel juste sur la
spontanéité ça se peut que tu laisses
pas de temps pour que ça arrive ça
arrivera pas exact exact puis briser les
scripts aussi c'était au avec Marie qui
nous avait parlé de ça quand était venu
sur le Podcast puis ça cétait comme
tombé dans une dans une boîte dans la
tête là tu sais que j'ai pas réouvert
vraiment ouais mais récemment j'ai
repensé j'ai fait oui dans le fond c'est
vrai que c'est un danger qui gute les
coupes parce que
tu tombes comme tu dis dans
l'utilitarisme ouais c'est ça puis il
faut pas que tu tombes là-dedans parce
que ça c'est le plus gros killer qui
donne pas envie de retourner là ouais
ouais tu sais Joan sexoral av déjà parlé
de ça aussi que tu sais activement pu
son chum comme ça blog du temps genre
une soirée par mois puis là mettons ils
font des des je sociétés sexuel mett
genre de où est-ce que tu pies une carte
puis là tu es faut que tu fasses de quoi
tu sais fait que là ça te sort de tes p
ça te fait découvrir petre des nouvelles
affaires ou c'est ça c'est intéressant
justement pour comme là il y a comme une
une tierce une force externe qui te en
guemet impose jamais vraiment imposé
mais tu sais qui te suggère les affaires
m qui peut-être pas voulu amener mais là
c'est la carte ouais ah c'est les d
c'est les d les d c'est juste 6 côtés
marqué
peging ah le D a
choisi le gars il truc c'est
d le D à parlé c'est bon
ah c'est bon ça man c'est des bons c'est
des bons in and out tu tu avais-tu autre
chose de In and Out ou on peut aussi
parler faire un petit ce qui s'en vient
pour le le studio SF ouais ouais ouais
tu sais les prochains podcasts parce
qu'on est quand même en mode Création
active je peux faire des in rapido là
vas-y moi
j'avais B ça c'est plus euh du point de
vue musical aussi là c'est comme on
dirait il y a une certaine époque où
est-ce
que pratiquer de la guitare c'est comme
la chose principale dans ma vie puis là
c'est comme ça existe la chose numéro 24
dans le sens que si j'ai 30 minutes une
fois dans la semaine c'est pas pire même
que des fois je peux passer fait de
ramener ça dans la routine c'est un des
trucs euh qu'est-ce qui se passe avec
excuse-moi C en même temps ça fait
longtemp on s'est parlé qu'est-ce qui se
passe avec le condo ou la maison
l'aménagement c'est quelque chose qui ça
ben oui ça ça fait partie des des in là
en cris des objectifs ah d'ailleurs j'ai
une histoire là-dessus ok euh
ouais moi pu ma blande on est encore en
recherche de de de de nouvelles demeur
là tu sais fait que moi j'ai ménagé chez
elle elle est propriétaire puis là on
voudrait probablement c'est pas une
nécessité c'est pas une absolu mais
probablement acheter de quoi ensemble
après bien ateur C bref on regarde ça
puis moi une de mes un de mes critère
important c'est d'avoir au moins une
place où est-ce que je peux me faire une
pièce musique fa avoir un peu plus
d'espace puis spoiler alert on on veut
avoir une chambre supplémentaire comme
ça si on veut des kids là tu sais je ve
dire ça ça ça ça se peut que ça soit
dans un an mais ça ça soit dans 6 ans
aussi ou dans qui sait mais pour avoir
besoin de déménager comme tu sais si ça
arrive quand ça arrive pas faire la
fameuse erreur du studio SF de déménager
dans une place juste un petit peu plus
grosse pour rapidement se rendre compte
qu'on a plus de place pour faire ce
qu'on veut faire exct exact c'est ça
déménager bref les deux ensemble
beaucoup de critèr l'autre jour on a
visité une place
puis justement chaque place qu'on visite
c'est comme certains points positifs
certains points négatif mais c'est dur
d'avoir tout la seule façon d'avoir ça
c'est de se construire
ouais ou de payer 1 million c'est chose
pas d'avoir aucune limite Budet c'est ça
exact c'est ça la limite du budget puis
de tous nos critères c'est rare qu'on a
tout faut que tu fasses des compromis
mais là c'est c'est tout le temps à quel
point tu fais des compromis versus
acheter quelque chose qui est pas
parfait jour à Verdin onit on voit un
condo on va visiter ça puis c'est sur
duprio sais c'est pas d'agentit je je
m'attends à rencontrer le propriétaire
de la place on arrive là un peu vide pas
vraent de meuble le est là un peu puis
clairement il habite pas là puis lui
dans le
fond rapidement comprend
que acheté ça il rénové un
peu classique technique je pas le seul à
monéal à faire
ça en fait crime ouis ça aura été plus
fun d'acheter ça à une petite famille ou
à quelqu'un que genre juste un d' qui
flipe puis qui revend ça mais qu'est-ce
que tu veux ça te regarde pas vraiment
non mais là on fait un gen de background
check ce gars là puis là on se rend
compte que il est
genre reconnu à comme le requin de
Verdun [__] comme lui là genre il il
achet des des des quadruplexes il renipe
un peu là vraiment genre de de tu sais
de de de cosmétique là de de façade puis
il revend ça fucking
cher puis genre puis il y a plein il y a
des articles dans le devoir des articles
Journal de Montréal genre qui parleent
de lui de ses pratiques de comment qui
est agressif avec que lui achète puis tu
en réalité tuas il y a certaines euh il
y a certains cas où est-ce que tu peux
mettre quelqu'un dehors là genre si tu
veux habiter dedans mais tu sais
normalement tu peux pas faire ça là tu
sais puis là lui utilise toutes les
stratégies puis là il menace le monde
puis là il fait du chantage pour comme
puis vraiment juste comme B crissement
insistant pour que le monde crisse leur
camp ouais puis euh puis genre il y a
même des mettons il y a une manif contre
la gentrification à Verdun ou est-ce que
du monde qui ont fait des discours genre
qui s'adresse à lui puis car genre lui
là tu sais ouais puis genre c'est ça va
jusqu'à il y a un monsieur ça faisait 40
ans qu' habitait dans son logement de
Verdun qui avait sa petite vie là tu
sais genre c'est un monsieur de genre 75
ans tu sais à cet âge là ton petit ton
petit monde tes petites
habitudes puis là lui il l' il l' kické
out puis d'ailleurs il y a une loi
semble-t-il qui protège ça pour les gens
de 70 ans et plus pour pas qu'il se
fasse genre tu peux pas juste les
crisser dehors de chez eux lui s'est
défendu en disant qu'il savait pas le
monsieur s'est suicidé m genre puis là
toutes ces voisins disaient c'était un
homme il était heureux là tu sais il
allait bien il était tu sais c'était pas
quelqu'un qui était suicidaire quelqu'un
qui était dépressif mais ça l' tellement
décolcé de voir déménager de de changer
de de de de d'univers puis de changer
de de c'est la jobetouvver une place
abordable tuas retrouvé ça fait 40 ans
que tu es la même place monsieur s'est
suicidé men fait que genre là je suis
comme moi je pense honnêtement
bahcuse-moi mais ça pour dire que là ce
condo là c'était le le condo le meilleur
cond mon qu'on a visité qu'on avait
visité à date si vous avez décidé de pas
le prend pour le prix ben
là on est pas parti pour le prendre là
dans le sens qu'on le visité un peu
avant les fightes par on est tombé en
mode fight puis euh on va en a reparler
là mais tu
sais puis tu sais le pire c'est que le
gars il va le vendre à quelqu'un d'autre
là il va le vendre genre il il va même
principe que le que le le le poulet à
l'épicerie là ouais Benou je l'achètees
pas quelqu'un qui va l'acheter
ouais une fois qu' est rendu là là moi
envieê celui qui met mon argent dans son
compte à lui
exact vu tout ce qu'il fait tu sais en
tout cas ex mais ça m moi je pense que
c'est un des plus gros problèmes qu'on a
en tant que société c'est la spéculation
sur des droits fondamentaux là la
spéculation sur des choses qui
sont nécessaires à la survieou fait
mettons même même chose tu sais
l'habitation of course mais c'est ce
qu'on
reproche aux épiceries c'est ce qu'on
reproche aux compagnies pharmaceutiqu
Mo je suis pas contre le Big pH ou gen
l'industrie pharmaceutique que je suis
contre c'est la spéculation puiser les
prix quand tuas le monopole sur de quoi
qui Chris ça guérit le
diabète des affaires de même fait la
spéculation sur des trucs comme ça puis
la spéculation immobilière sur TikTok il
y a vraiment un sub sur TikTok c'est des
mini micro Bull quand tu tombes dans un
affaire de même t'en propose plein des
choses que tu sais pas qui existait puis
je suis tombé làdessus dernièrement
c'est un post sur Twitter puis quand je
fais des post sur Twitter c'est rare que
ça cartonne ben pas que ça cartonne mais
c'est même rare on dirait qu'il a
quelqu'un qui le voit là il avait au
moins comme 30 likes sur mon post c'est
30 lik c'est énorme d'habit c'est un
souvent zéro tu
sais qui me fait questionner sur est-ce
que je derais continuer à utiliser la
plformme tu dis bien inves mais CIT un
gars qui s'est fait donner une amende de
70000 pièces parce qu'
expulser je je juste lire mon je juste
lire article que j'ai partagé ok ok e je
je viens d'ouvrir mon seel 20
notifications nouveaux messages j' en
avait zéro avant qu'on commence le
podcast horri euh Twitter ok fait mon
mon
tweet ce que j'ai partagé dans le fond
c'est l'article c'est 20000 dollars
d'amende un jeune proprioot condamné
pour avoir expulsé illégalement sa
locataire de 77 ans elle a été évincé
alors que son fils venait d'être
hospitalisé pour une leucémie puis là il
y a une photo du gars OK de de lui
là il doit avoir 24 25 ansoua euh un
jeune gars là tu sais puis sur tik
tookok il y a un sub rit un sub tik
tookok de
tioun de 22 à 28 mettons là qui parle de
se faire un empire de porte h fait genre
comment com comment acheter ton premier
ton premier quadruplexe comment acheter
tes premières portes comment comment
rentrer sur le marché comment puis là
c'est ce monde là qui pense que l'argent
c'est lo qu'aler là fait il s'en cissent
de comment ils la font l'argent là ils
font quelque chose qui est pas
nécessaire au mondeou qui sert à
personne juste pour faire de l'argent
pour faire de l'argent sur le dos du
monde qui veulent juste vivre m fait que
là ce gars là m il connaî pas les règles
du bâtiment il soncore de tu sais pour
faire ça c'est parce que tu en as aucune
idée c'est quoi les règles lui il achète
son plex man il crisse une madame à
porte qui qui a pas une scè à 77 ans M
genre tu réalises tout ce que tu fais
ouais c'est quelqu'un qui habite là
c'est une habitation de quelqu'un man
toi toi quand tu roules la Audi de ton
père men à fucking Laval là tu penses-tu
à Madame de 77 ans qui a pas vraiment de
fond de pension qui a son fils qui vient
à t'atteindre la leucémie que toi tu
crisses dehors de chez eux pour faire
plus d'argent sur un plex que
probablement que c'est ton père qui t'a
donné le cashdown pour acheter ton plex
tu penses-tu à ça tu penses juste à ça
te crée un empire de porte m ça me fait
tellement chier là ça me fait tellement
chier l'espèce de culture de vouloir
faire de l'argent pour de l'argent pour
sans même penser à ce que tu fais ouais
je moi je jeis un entrepreneur oui mais
tu entreprends quoi M c'est tu sers à
qui tu sers juste à faire de l'argent à
toi ou tu sers à quelque chose de plus
grand que toi que ton propre
portefeuille je veux un empire de porte
ta gueule un empire de quoi un empire de
de bien gen un empire de faire chier le
monde un empire de monter tes prix c'est
fou là c'est fou c'est des des
augmentation de de prix qui ont pas de
sens pour les habitations pu le problème
il est là c'est c'est ce GS GS que tu
parles le monsieur de 77 de 70 ans là
qui se fait crisser dehors il a habité
là toute sa fucking vie il se fait
crisser dehors il regarde autour de lui
toutes les autres apparts pour sa
qualité de vie il faudrait qu'il paye
300 pièces de plus par mois il y a pas
de sortie ce gars là lui a planifié sa
sa retraite pour ouais pour le prix qu'
paye se fait coler dehors par lui e une
montée de lait non mais montée de lait
justifié pour vrai là ça fait chier il y
a vraiment du monde qui font chier
vraiment des As croté puis il y a
personne qui va aucun de ces croté là
qui va entendre ce que je dis en ce
moment là mais j'espère qu' en a
peut-être un qui va faire peut-être
qu'en ce moment là l'immobilier puis la
prospection immobilière peut-être que
c'est pas la chose la plus éthique à
faire là peut-être que si je veux me
partir en business je pourrais je sais
pas mais partir une business de
nettoyage de tapis ici on en a besoin
justement on va êre vos premers clients
on va être vos premiers clients
écrivez-nous j'ai décidé d'abandonner
mon idée d'acheter un plex puis à PL je
va venir laver des tapis ok man cool
fair en à place de faire ton es crotter
puis crisser du monde à la porte
mais ouais c'est c'est DESC ça ça c'est
pu c'est encore une fois c'est tout le
temps les mêmes qui payent là c'est les
plus vulnérables
vé les moins favorisé les autres qui ex
ils pensent qu'ils vont être good dans
leur appartement puis c'est finalement
première chose qu'il savent c'est comme
non exact là tuas la ministre de de
l'habitation men qui qui est une
propriaire une propriétaire de bloc
appartement puis qui fait des des lois
pour les propriétaires sans défendre les
pro sans défendre les locatairesouais
tout le monde est là let's go on
continue on continue continue mais moi
mettons plot twist les sessions de
bail je comprends le outrage mais ça me
scandalise pas tant que ça moi non plus
les sessions de bail Non je vais
t'expliquer pourquoi parce que les
sessions de bail mettons
les gens qui ont accès à ça c'est si tu
es chanceux ouais c'est si tu es dans un
groupe facebook puis que le timing est
vraiment bon puis là que tu connais
quelqu'un si tu es chanceux tu V avoir
un appart un est bon prix de comment
qu'est-ce ça coûtait 5 10 15
ans tout le reste du monde il paye
vraiment trop cher tu as du monde qui
paye vraiment en dessous les chanceux
puis tu as du monde qui paye le le prix
du marché des quand je démage le 1er
juillet puis que je signe directement c
le propri en haut puis ça en général
c'est trop cher fait que tu sais moi
pour moi le problème je veux dire les
session de B c'est comme un genre de
loop h euh intéressant pour les
locataires ça c'est sûr tu sais puis ça
ça l' aidé ben du monde ça aide du monde
mais je veux dire le le fond du problème
il est pas là le fond du problème c'est
que l'immobilier est trop cher les
propriétaires je dire il y a des gens
qui profitent du pauvre monde c'est à ça
qu'il faut s'attaquer là c'est comme
c'est de baisser le plafond pas pas en
tout cas
fa si ça me scandalise un peu parce que
s'il y a pas d'autres mesures qui
viennent
contrebalancer ça que les les gens
moyens vont pouvoir profiter ben là
finalement c'est encore les les plus
pauvres qui perdent ou mais je pense que
la solution au final est pas là est pas
là non non est pas là est pas là dans
construire plus de logement mettre des
des des toits sur le des plafonds sur
les pr puis on avait parlé avec
Jean-Martin de ça là tu sais puis qui
dit que ça devrait être régi par quelque
chose de ça devrait pas être juste la
loi du marché c'est trop primimordial
parce que la loi du marché en plus avec
la croissance de la population puis
l'immigration
massive le le prix du marché va toujours
exploser vers la hausse là tu sais ça va
ça aura pas de sens tout le temps tu
sais mais ouais effectivement je suis
d'accord avec ça fait fait finalement
vous prenez pas cette place ben je pense
pas qu'on va la prendre surtout
aprèsavoir parlé sur le Podcast j'a un
peu tout faitle tourne de bord il fait
une offre d'ACh l' demain là ouais
mais mais non mais mais ce ce qui Go
c'est que au final mais moi en fait la
raison principale c'est
que comme je trosse pas ce gars
là tu trosses pas l'appart je trosse pas
l'appart c'est un appart ou un cond
c'est un condo mais au final je dire
c'est un quadruplex qui était locatif
avant c'est des apparts là je
dire
c'est la même affaire c'est juste que il
est à toi mais jeoua niveau euh comment
que comment tu entends ton voisin ou
comment tu sais tout ça c'est c'est
c'est comme un appart moyen à Montréal
je veux dire c'est pas c'est pas
différent fait que on dirait tu sais
puis quand qu'on posé des questions tu
lu construitire une belle galerie en
arrière puis repeinturé puis tu sais
quand tu rentres c'est c'est clean
mettant mais quand on posé des questions
sur la toiture sur la plomberie ou sur
les fondations il y a aucune C
bah il disait je sais pas mais tu sais
c'est comme tu le saches ou sera
intéressant que tu le saches peut- que
tu le sais puis c'est vraiment weird le
lendemain s quandon est allé était il a
vraiment l'attitude au début comme il en
confiancece qui une attitude chill genre
tu sais prenez votre temps pensez à ça
puis sais en ce moment c'est vraiment
comment qui a dit ça c'est vraiment un
marché d'acheteurs en ce moment là c'est
vraiment avantageux pour les acheteurs
en ce moment puis tu sais je sais
comment en même temps les taux ouais
mais vu que les taux sont haut ben les
prix sont plus bas puis ça se garoche
moins pu c'est comme fa en là mais genre
le lendemain qu'on visite il me forward
un email d'une fille qui dit e je suis
intéressé je v s en faire une vraiment
bientôt il me forward un email avec
l'adresse email de la fille puis tout je
suis comme soit tu es assez psychopate
pour avoir créé un un faux échange
d'email avec une fausse adresse email
d'une fille pour me mettre la pression
ou tu forward des données renseignement
personnel l'adresse email de la fille à
n'importe qui genre dans les deux cas
c'est weird comme pratique en chis là tu
sais ouais fait que bref ouais je trosse
pas assez C pour acheter mais là tu as
trop de Red Flag ça amené qu une limite
supérieure de Red Flag que tu peux avoir
avant de faire un move aussi gros que ça
ouais c'est ça c'est tu retrouvé avec
euh t retrouvé avec des des défauts puis
des affaires même dans un
mieêre locataire que ça vraiment h ouais
ah c'est
ça bref ça c'est
la la parenthèse condo parenthèse
habitation habitation ouais fait que
sinon concrètement mettons sans être des
inou des toi tuas-tu des j'imagine ça
revient un peu au Mme tu avais-tu des
résolutions genre 2024 ben tu sais tu
avis l'alcool ouais l'alcool c'est pas
une résolution
nécessairement mais une résolution
euh je pense que ma résolution première
c'est ce que je te disais au début là
pas les chibidou mais juste après là
quand que je disais que j'avais besoin
de prendre une pause comme BBO là
ouaisoua j'ai besoin de trouver un sweet
spot m qui est pas cel-là que j'ai là
fait que faut que je trouve c'est quoi
faut que je trouve est-ce que c'est
juste parce que c'était la fin du 4e
trimestre puis que j'étais juste brûlé
de l'année est-ce que c'est juste que
tout est arrivé en même temps m dans
dans ma vie là tu sais est-ce que c'est
aussi que je faisais beaucoup de route
dans dernier 6 mois pu ça c'est ça c'est
taxant quand même faire la route il y a
quelque chose que j'ai fait dans dernier
3 4 mois qui est pas durable puis il
faut je trouve c'est quoi puis faut je
le
règle fait que ça c'est la question ça
c'est pas une résolution mais ma
résolution c'est de trouver c'est quoi
mais tu t'es combien d' par jour une à
1h de ah ok des fois je fais 2h de une
fois par semaine ok je pensais que
c'était 2h 2h non non non ok non pas en
ce moment des fois je l'ai fait là mais
pas pas là pas dans les derniers 3 mois
derniers 3 mois je v plus c'est ça le
pire c'est que je m'entraîne pas mal
moins que je m'entraîne pendant le pic
de la saison m mais il y a quelque chose
puis c'était pas charge physique là je
suis pas non mais dans le sens que c'est
quand même dans le sens que pour
quelqu'un qui a qui travaille temp plein
s'entraîner 1h 1h30 2h par jour ça
commence à faire tu tes dans ta journée
en stti ouais mais tu sais je veux dire
quand tu
pas c'est plus la fatigue mentale
qu'autre chose mon affaire c'est plus
l'impression de courir après ma queue
puis de pas la rattraper jamais puis
faut que je trouve c'est quoi gen faut
je trouve c'est quoi ce spot là pu ça
c'est ma résolution on essayer de
trouver c'est quoi pour peut-être que
c'est plus du slow living mon affire h
peut-être que c'est ça je sais pas
exactement
encore peut-être j'ai besoin de plus de
slow living peut-être que ça revient un
peu à ce qu'on disait de lâcher mon sel
c'est peut-être que tout ça est comme
est comme relié là si je lâche mon sel
que je reviens chez nous je lis des
livres que je que je chill un peu plus
que je prends plus de soleil que je
prends plus le temps de ça c'est un
autre affaire tu sais parce que
j'ai sans rentrer trop dans les détails
é es quand même pris à gorge
monétairement pendant un bon bout dansun
dernier temps làou puis là j'ai là j'ai
moins ça beaucoup moins
puis là là je pourrais partir une
semaine
dans le sud à une fréquence assez assez
fréquente mettons quand qui fait pas
beau quand je commence à être dans je
pourrais faire ça ouis ça je pense que
je vais le faire plus puis en sachant
tout les détriments environnementaux que
ça implique là mais pé les billets pour
être carbone la compensation carbone la
compensation carbone de mes voyages mais
mais au moins peut-être que c'est ça
plus de soleil plus de mais moi je pense
vraiment que
comme la constante stimulation de
regarder quelque chose c'est comme ça ça
t'alourdit la tête tu sais veut pas le
sel c'est comme ce que le s est tr c'est
qu' s'est associé au travail puis s
associé au divertissement aussi parce
que tu check les réseaux sociaux mais
genre les réseaux sociaux tuas aussi tes
messages là-dessus fait que là c comme
tu es en mode chill mais tu es aussi en
mode gen je reç un message je répondre
fait que c'est comme finalement tu y a
pas de coupure franche
entre fait que ouais j'ai l'impression
que ça ça ça joue aussi là d'enlever ça
d'enlever l'espèce de noise constant
genre ouais faire les trucs plus les
trucs de manière consciente puis de
laisser plus de place au silence puis
ouais je pense que c'est c'est ça ma
résolution toi c'est ça aussi euh ça
çaen a une
euh moi j'ai j'ai une résolution
vraiment
euh vraiment
[Musique]
euh classique là puis vraiment euh je
sais pas comment dire euh aller au gym
te remettre en forme ben je vois déjà au
gym puis je me considè déjà en forme
mais mettons
euh j'ai j'ai genre les gens vont me
lancer des roches puis me me dire que
j'ai de la per po tu es malade mental on
touche pas à ça on touche plus à ça tu
es malade mental M droit de le dire pas
dire ça tu es un fou m pas le droit de
le dire tu un fou m il y a rien je
voulais faire le joke j'ais pas de
chiffre ok tu sais des fois excuse-moi
on revient on revient à ton en par que
tu as le droit d'en parler parce que ça
te concerne toi ok mais tu sais tu sais
tu sais que des fois dans ma tête je
pens à genre si j'avais un une heure de
standup comicque à faire j'ai certains
gag des fois je je les workshop genre là
j'ess de workshoper une joke autour de
il y a rien qui qui a vieilli plus mal
puis plus vite
que de parler de poids m ouais parce que
2 ans il y avait de bigest loser à télé
puis personne disait rien pu enant 2 ans
tu mentionnes le mot poids tu un débile
mental puis je trouvais pas vraiment
langue comment tourner ça à J parce que
je suis pas un humoriste une idée pour
les humoristes qui nous écoutent bref
bref tu un fou tu'en va parler de ça fou
un de considé ça comme notre dernier
Podcast on va se faire Canel il toutes
les fois qu'on a pu se faire cancel
qu'on est tu encore là puis que toi là
tu vas nous faire c ouis à cause que je
veux moi-même cause que mo-être perd du
PO non mais je me suis paisé là me P
jamais là vraiment là tu sais ouais puis
là genre chez mes parents il ont comme
genre une genre de balance de médecin là
tu sais genre de balance fucking précise
là ouais
puis j'étais le plus lourd que j'ai
jamais été ouais comme fait puis sais
pourtant je m'entraî mais tempsci je
fais
plus commencer un nouveau programme
ok paren
March sais insanity avec
Shanty là Shanty j'ai vu qu'il sortait
un nouveau programme mais là c'est
inanity mais en
mode lift en mode muscu genre c'est
comme c'est quand même un vidéo que tu
técoutes puis tu le suis tu fa en real
time mais tu fais au gym ou à Mo tu
plein de Dumbell chez vous là tu sais
mais avec des Dumbell de
plusieurs de GR po puis là bon bref que
tu fais les MOV mett classique là haut
du corps bas du corps shoulder chest
sais dépendamment des
joursessay de le trouver bref je l'ai
pas trouvé mais j'en ai trouvé un autre
qui dans ce genre là fait que là j'tais
comme ch je vais essayer ça parce
que on dirait que je veux faire
l'entraînement musculaire mais cris que
genre j'ai la misèire à me motiver tout
seul puis je trouve ça long genre je
trouve ça plate faire une série un autre
série puis là je le temps par prendre
des pauses vraiment trop longues genre
parce que personne qui qui botent le cul
fa ton autre série parce que ça c'est ça
tu le fais real time fait que là tu sais
quand le 30 secondes il fini il fini tu
V là bref je fais
ça puis ça fait de semaines ça va bien
mais je sais pas là j'ai quelque chose
pas optimal je pense qu'il faut
que je rajoute du cardio làdedans là je
sais pas trop là parce que là on dirait
que je me
trouve lourd je comprends mais là
lancez-moi des roches si vous voulez là
ce ce qui est in je v te le dire ce qui
est in là c'est le triathlon le
triathlon c'est in en CH parce que dans
les dans le dernier temps juste genre
dans le monde sur Instagram que je suis
là ouais il y a beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup de créateurs de contenu qui
commence le triathlon qui vise un demi
ou un full Iron Man dans la prochaine
année beaucoup là je pourrais t'en
nommer au moins 10 qui font ça ça c'est
in puis moi depuis que j'ai commencé à
avoir cette mentalité làà de vouloir
faire ça h vouloir m'entraîner pour le
triathlon le triathlon c'est ce que je
réalisais pas parce que je j'avais
jamais fait vraiment de vélo h puis je
comprenais pas c'était quoi le vélo
nécessairement dans le triathlon je
comprenais pas c'était quoi le challenge
du vélo dans le tri je comprenais pas
c'était le vélo venait travailler quoi
jusqu'àendant que je commence à enfire
pour vrai OK puis ça vient traver
quelque chose de complètement différent
que les deux autres sports complètement
différent c'est genre de l'endurance
musculaire sur le long long terme mais
de l'endurance musculaire c'est pas
juste tourner tes pieds pour tourner tes
pieds c'est comme faut que tu paèises
ses pédales puis là tu viens vider tes
jambes c'est le feeling que j'ai là
quand je fais des rid mettons 2h là tu
as l'impression d'avoir les jambes vide
mais tu es encore capable d'y aller pu
c'est pas le cardio qui travaille la
course c'est le cardio puis laotation
c'est complet c'est tellement complet
comme sport c'est tellement complet puis
c'est sans impact le seul la seule sport
qui a de l'impact dans le triathlon
c'est la course puis quand tu
t'entraînes pour du triathlon mais tu
peux pas faire des semaines à 100 kg de
course fait c'est pas dangereux tu fais
des semaines max à 60 kg mett max si tu
t'entraînes beaucoup mais souvent le
monde sont à 40 kg de course un genre de
TR fois 12 FO 12 kg dans une semaine
puis c'est tellement complet je trouve
ça magnifique je trouve que c'est fou
parce que la natation nous on a la
chance d'être bon fa de l'avoir
naturellement mais de pouvoir aller dans
l'eau puis de danger sans de faire un
3000 m sans que ça a l'air d'être un
effort olympique là fait que ça c'est
complet musculaire tuallonges les
muscles tu p ton dos tu t'étires dépoges
les vertèbres le cor c'est tu allonges
les les articulation après ça tu vas sur
le vélo pour de l'endurance puis tu fais
pas chier sur le vélo là tu sa c'est
beau c'est le fun c'est des longs
moments en zone 1 la course ben c'est
vraiment efficace parce que tu sors de
chez vous tu V courir tout ça mis
ensemble c'est le melting pot ultime
puis depuis que j'ai commencé à faire du
vélo sur mon ZFT sur la machine eurs o
est-ce que là tu mixes gaming puis puis
sport c'est tellement le fun j'ai jamais
autant de F à m'entraîner que j'en ai en
ce moment de toute ma vie même quand je
faisais du sprint là puis de la notation
high level j'ai jamais autant de fun que
ça parce que c'est tout en même temps
puis à chaque jour il y a une nouvelle
affaire qui travaille un autre affaire
différente puis qui il vient additionner
sur les briques que tu mets dans ton mur
de fitness c'est vraiment cool puis il y
a pas de danger de blessure il y a pas
de c'est le
triathlon écoute je va
penser for en plus je sais pas je su s
que oui ser fort ça fait des années je
m'entraîne pour des AFFS vraiment plus
court bonne raison de
s'allonger bon on VI faire nots on vient
faire on vient ici on fait notre un
objectif juste pour finir 2024 faire
dem
vite ouais parce que je sais que demain
matin je ferai un demi Iron Man
facilement demain là tu sais mais de
faire un demi Iron Man vite
genre niveau là intense c'est ça mon
objectif l'ER
prochain toi
ah puis ça c'est genre il y a plein
d'autres objectifs que j'ai lié à ma
business à mes business puis des trucs
comme ça là mais ça c'est plus comme
côté hobby là en ce moment c'est
vraiment un hobby puis j'aime vraiment
ça moi ben on parler de plein d'affaire
en fait je posé la question puis sans
avoir préparé ma réponse combien de
livres tu veux lire cette année mais toi
un objectif de Liv lu
ouais ça peut être
ça sinon ben dans les choses
qu'on faut vraiment que je règle mes
problèmes de dos aussi là parce que là
j'ai dos pétéit ça ser un objectif de
comme essayer de 2025 pu avoir mal au
dos pu pu être tout le temps pé ouais ça
serait pas
P puis
sinon sortir de la musique oui oui oui
on peut pas dévoiler ton nom d'artiste
encore
euh non je faire une mais faut que j'ai
faut que tu l'entendre ta musiqueis tu
l'entendre elle existe là existe je pe
faire écouter là ouais onécoutera on est
écouter écter là ouais ouais parfait ok
ça ça r vient mais ça c'est c'est sûr ça
va sortir parce que là j'ai pratiquement
finiit à moins que je ch la sortie mais
penserait pas rendu là tu le dis là tu
le mets open on dittu le nom on dirait
que je suis curieux non mais c'est parce
que au final ça reste moi c'est pas moi
qui décide ça je va faire mon annonce
quand même un jour puis je pense pas que
ça va chier ça là c'est que les gens qui
écoutent jusqu'à la fin du podcast
écoute la fin du podcastvez allez
commenter qu ouais puis venez nous
écrire si vous aimez je révéler si vous
plaît prenez le temps juste pour pour
qu'on voit aussi un peu qui qui fin je
vais révéler
euh ce qui en ce moment ce que j'ai
décidé qui est mon nom d'artiste mon
projet de de musique originale de style
chanson francophone ouais fait
que ça ça c'est polarisant je vous
avertis mais mon nom d'artiste
adolp
tabarnac c'est
ce serait
minou solide minou penseadore on aime on
aime pas on écrit en
commentaire vous avez des meilleures
suggestions jamais pouvez vous commenter
pu peut-être que je Chang d'idé pere
que d'entendre minouend minou onant
après la pause
minou alors minou bienvenue à Tout le
monde en parle alors pourquoi vous avez
décidé ce nom min
pire imitation merci gang bonne année
2024 puis on se rejoint dans de semaines
avec des nouveaux podcast a des invités
super
intéress continue Contin